Britney Spears spotted outside of the
health facility she checked herself into
earlier this month the singer was
snapped with boyfriend Samus Gauri on
Easter Sunday
leaving the montage hotel in Beverly
Hills Sam looks to be protectively
shielding Britney a source tells e.t
Britney is still in treatment but is
finding it hard to be away from her
son's 13 year old Shawn and 12 year old
Jayden quote she wants nothing more than
to heal and feel better she has improved
while in the facility but not going home
yet those that love and support her say
she needs to focus on herself it hasn't
been easy for her to be away from her
children there's been days where it's
been harder for me than other days of
course my philosophy is just take each
day at a time
this isn't the first time Britney has
left the facility for an outing et
previously reported on April 11th she
left to get her hair done at a salon
earlier this month ET learned Britney
checked herself into the facility to
deal with the tremendous stress she's
been having over her father Jamie Spears
current health crisis you hold on to
family when you go through hard times
like that in January Spears announced
she would be taking an indefinite Work
hiatus to focus on her father's recovery
after a near-death health incident she
shared the news on Instagram writing in
part a couple of months ago my father
was hospitalized and almost died we're
all so grateful that he came out of it
alive but he still has a long road ahead
of him I had to make the difficult
decision to put my full focus and energy
on my family at this time I hope you all
can understand
[Music]